[Music]
oh I didn't let it hit too I didn't let
hit
one all right it's never going to hit
one I dictate things around here not
that timer what's going on you guys it's
Lord ad here gaming ad here coming at
you with another video Oh wrong wrong
format what's going on you guys
appreciate you all coming through uh
welcome to another adct show we talk
about the past present future G I got my
Coast with me D GRE what's going on D
what's up my brother how you doing doing
pretty good man what you you been
playing you know there's a lot of stuff
going on right now but what you've been
playing adct I am a bot so I've been
playing Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 3 I just finished
the
campaign how you liking it I thought it
was good man I mean I'm not listen was
was it a four out of 10 good it
definitely was not a four out of 10 it
was yeah I'm pretty sure it was
definitely shorter than some of the
other
campaigns but I thought it was pretty
solid man I mean I thought it was good
and I'm not just being super biased even
though I am biased for this particular
topic I am not biased I thought the game
was pretty decent and the multiplayer is
pretty solid
also yeah it's it's been a pretty hectic
thing going on man you know uh one thing
I want to you know point out is just
like the amount of games that we have is
just is intense it really is like it it
feels like we ain't ever gonna run out
right it really does it feels like
gaming is just going to be this way
forever and I
know I'm not looking forward to the
crashing
part where 2024 is it gonna be this
living you know what I'm saying yeah
like when we have to go back to playing
a fire game every five months instead of
every other month or every month yeah
because I feel like the there was good
games every year just some you know
probably were critically claim more but
especially that the later part of 2023
is just is just absurd like just just
crazy amounts of and part of me a little
I'm a little little worried about it
yeah yeah man um like after I'm about to
go back I'm playing RoboCop now actually
since I finished Cod going to finish
Robocop and then I'll probably go back
to you know Jedi Fallen
Survivor Jedi yeah Jedi Survivor um I
still want to finish Hogwarts didn't
finish that still want to finish
Starfield didn't finish that so it's
some few game it's a few games I
definitely want to go back and finish
yeah it's it's a lot man I've been
playing a lot of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
I heard that's good man like one of my
boys on my podcast said that's good now
don't get me wrong if you don't know how
this game functions you it's going to be
it's rough at the beginning it's rough
because you have to like learn I I'm
trying to learn how to play Victor
um you know actually a lot of people on
Twitter should learn that because
they're all acting like they victims but
anyway you know I'm trying to learn how
to play the
victims and I I'm using this chick named
Connie her her special ability is when
she uses her ability she can Auto pick
locks pretty much so you know I'm
actually enjoying it more than I enjoyed
uh dead by daylight I know a lot of
people like dead by daylight I'm
enjoying it more than that not probably
not as much as Friday the 13 because I
felt like that was a phenomenal like
Friday the 13th was just on another
level but I do recommend you guys try
you know we we got a uh we got a visitor
man uh G what's going on G hey guys how
are you can you hear me yeah we yes sir
excellent I'm doing great guys nice to
be on yeah we there's a little bit of a
feedback on your end I don't know what
that is like like a little buzz a little
static oh yeah a little buzz
yeah turn down your bass maybe that's
what it is I don't know yeah let's see
I'm talking I'm talking is that okay I
could still hear okay that's good that's
good it's still there but it's not as
bad okay you let me know you just mute
when you're not talking um perect
so yeah someone said Connie's fire I'm
telling you guys that I hate to be the
be bad news good games like this I'm
scared it's just not going to take off
you know you know how it is like you
could have a phenomenal multiplayer game
and it still doesn't like hit the way it
should uh but you know besides that you
know G what are you playing you I'm sure
you've been playing
something uh oh yeah I'm I'm still on
the Nostalgia kick do you hear hear the
buzz still by the way a little bit but
it's not that bad yeah all right U my
apologies I actually have no idea what
this is but uh I'm still on the
Nostalgia kick I got my analog pocket
here so I'm just playing a bunch of of
Game Boy events games and stuff like
that and of course League of Legends and
all that stuff so oh you got a crazy
backdrop I actually really like that
backdrop you like that H you like that
look I got gimly because that's where I
got my name from gamley I messed up when
I was a little kid I totally misspelled
it I was like who's that dwarf's name
it's ginley gamley I think it's gamley
and then I used that as my name and I
messed
up me for it it worked out you know it's
a good name it's a good name name now
everybody calls me gamesley so you know
I'll take it I'll take it yeah we uh
have you got to get got to play that
textas chainsaw MRE
game uh I played it I think I played it
once with my brothers I I couldn't get
into it I was not good at that game
my trust me I wanted to drop that game
so many times but D I'm telling you once
you actually
learn they give you a tutorial but it's
not really a good tutorial they're like
okay this is how you Escape uh how it is
is like when you're the victim the
generators are on the outside of the
maps and they stop you from leaving but
you have a couple other things you can
leave you can leave through the Escape
patchet that's uh that's captured with
the uh the the pressure valve but you
have to find the the pressure Val and
you have to take the pressure Val
downstairs or upstairs depending on
where it is and you have to turn it on
and and The Killers can shut that sucker
once it's
open it's it's devastating it's
devastating and not to mention like you
know if you're a Survivor you can go
through nukes and crannies that like you
know leather faing them can't go but a
couple and I don't and I know [__] can
I don't know the rest but at least [__]
she's a killer she could go through
those same nukes and crannies that the
survivors could go through so like they
all got their different advantages like
if you're fighting Leatherface you
probably are good if you're downstairs
because even though he's deadly can kill
you with one or two hits he's easily
he's he's he's a lot slower and you're
able to get into these Maneuvers that he
just cannot follow you like if you do
anything like Leatherface is by far the
strongest but the weakest person in the
game by far because he's able to like
really do stuff hitchhiker uh soing The
Hitchhiker The Hitchhiker he had his
ability is he can re uh he can look at
the footprints and it will literally
tell him where you
at nice so I'm sitting there there's
nothing worse and I know people in the
chat I know I'm going a little bit too
on about Texas Shin so my bad but
there's nothing worse to like staring
down The Hitchhiker and he's walking
around you're like oh okay he doesn't
see me and he and he nails down like
damn he's about to use that damn ability
Jes and then and then it says at the
bottom left the hitchhiker is has picked
up on your Footprints I'm like oh it's
time to
run it's I gotta try man I gotta try it
how do you think how do you think it's
doing because I know the Friday the 13th
game was
gigantic
um I think I think it just depends on
whether or not first off it's crossplay
so that really helps you know there's
nothing better than um you know the
PlayStation uh nothing but Killers
having nothing but PlayStation and U I'm
able to escape them every time I feel
like they're not used to communicating
with each other because they always
playing single player games that's my
that's just my take on it uh I hope it's
doing good I I do know the crossplay is
going to be very helpful it's in Game
Pass and and PC game pass so I'm
assuming there's a lot of fluctu of
people going on that uh it's it's priced
well it's like 30 bucks if you don't
pick it up so you know the good thing
about stuff like this that I see Game
Pass really helping is when you you go
into let's say okay I'm playing my
friend my friend uh Evan he's on
Playstation I'm like yo
play Texas Chainsaw Massacre with me
he's got a PlayStation so he gotta buy
it so now in order to play the game with
me he got to drop 30 bones so you know
and it's that's easier sell and I said
people said a 90% drop this because this
game is hard like this isn't a simple
game like Tex uh you know Friday the
13th it was one killer you have three
killers at you at all times in this
game I struggled with that yeah and it
gets very frustrating sometimes because
especially if the killers upstairs go
downstairs like really fast because when
they're downstairs it's three on four
but the problem is is you got at least
hitchhiker and [__] that can go
wherever the kill the the survivors can
go and and you got Leatherface just
running around but anyway let's let's
get into the actual topic before we just
continue well I continue to blather on
more and more U let we G to talk about
Star Wars
uh star oh my God Star Wars going ice
and no one reported it going ice but
I'mma say ever since factions was talked
about going ice I gotta say everything
everything bad now is it's it's
reportedly going on ice so pretty much
what's Happening Here is is it does look
like this game might lowkey be cancelled
it's just no one's officially came out
and said it jessu shrier did say that
there's he knows at least two people
working on it now now I don't know what
that means you know we have to we have
to really see how that means but you
know what I want your guys' opinion just
go over you know do you have any any
Nostalgia moments with this because I
know this is a relatively older game did
you play it back in the day so I'm kind
of curious you know we'll start off our
guest gazley
gamley
gamley by the way do you guys swear on
this podcast cuz I know Iron Lord's you
uh I I don't like the swearing but if
you I'm a little
B I'm more open to to slip UPS than than
than Cog and King okay cuz I definitely
it was very hard on iron Lords
um the the um I I'm a huge Star Wars
nerd like if if I just if you look right
here see these see I got both like I I
got the 50th Anniversary there you go
Xbox
controller I got also the Mandalorian
one see that oh that's cool oh that one
sweet yeah yeah that's really cool it's
really nice so I got I got all these
controllers I love them to death um I
love the IP I was super excited kind of
like Maddie from defining Dukes I was
super excited when they announced it uh
I I don't really care about Sony being
involved but I really love that game and
it's started on Xbox so I wanted I
really wanted that to make um make an
appearance again um so I'm super
disappointed my my first thought super
disappointment but then I was
like well Xbox wins you know maybe we
could grab that maybe we could grab it
yeah okay so you know first D I do want
to pre on that because I I did make a
video on it um I I want to roll back to
that on the Xbox aspect of it uh but
right now D do you have any you know
history playing kns of the Old Republic
cure no unfort excuse me unfortunately
I'm not a huge Star Wars guy um so me I
do yeah I know man I know but I get him
out of
here I do remember it being on the
original Xbox um I do remember it being
a very popular game and I also remember
when it was announced for the
PlayStation as a PlayStation exclusive
um were excited for it so you know it's
unfortunately uh you know some people
that was looking forward to the game
they're not going to get it but but like
you say it's it's gamley right
gamesley gamley
gamley gamley like you said hey maybe
this is opportunity
for you know maybe Xbox can do something
maybe Phil sper knew that Aspire or
whatever the name of that development
team was maybe he knew that team
wasn't up up to the up for the job of
porting uh to uh porting that game so I
don't know man um maybe the game is just
dead right now I I I can't see it coming
out at this point so okay now that we
talked about the history thing let's
let's back this up and talk about the
Xbox because I feel like you're going
into that territory a little bit all
right so not really though okay then
then I am pushing us to that that
the conversation want that to Happ
so here's my thing I feel like
PlayStation has really really captivated
and benefited from having Final Fantasy
7 remake from having you know a lot of
this Nostalgia thing
Spider-Man well not necessarily
Spider-Man because like you know that's
more of an iconic character not
necessarily a game that's been remade so
like to me
because to me and I don't know maybe you
guys I personally feel like PlayStation
done cut ties run from the hills ejected
all money they had into this thing I
don't think they're involved anymore I
personally don't because they did did
you see where they they they privated
the uh the videos all the videos related
even on the social media I was told even
on the social medias they have they have
privated or deleted to me that screams
we ain't part of this anymore we want
nothing to do with this that that's
that's what I see and to me if that is
the case and there is no legal terms and
and they have truly let go of the
relationship with this company me on my
stance I'm like this is a really good
time for Xbox to capitalize and not only
get like a beloved remake that everyone
loves they they can get their own little
card because Final Fantasy 7 remake has
been a thorn in their side for a while
and also I would argue that this game
has more right to be on the Xbox
platform than PlayStation because it
kind of originated not necessarily
originated but it had a lot of shine
when it was and I and to me I don't know
but I under the assumption because I
never went back and looked the the N
little republics are exclusive to the
Xbox platform the old ones I don't think
they're on play
now obviously they're on PC so to me
this is the perfect opportunity to be
like yo even we have to to to to hit the
reset button you know go there laran
Studios or however you pronounce them I
don't care how you guys gonna sit there
and say even lar larryan studio if you
go over be like yo here's a bag remake
this
game I feel like it would be big for
Xbox now I know dirt's probably going to
disagree cuz he loves disagreeing with
me when when it comes to Xbox doing
things like this I don't know we the
biggest thing we argue about is just
comic book here maybe he he'll agree to
this but d i i i leave the floor to you
on this particular matter well I mean
come on when it comes to Star Wars
listen even though I'm not a huge fan
but there's no there's no secret that is
very popular
franchise if they can somehow get this
game and find a developer that can do
the game at a a a quality remake of it
100% hell yeah they should do it no no
doubt about it um I'm sure Phil Spencer
is probably thinking about it right now
you know what's the what what is the act
what's the thing that you guys disagree
on with with the Marvel
stuff as I as I understand is it that is
it that dirt doesn't think they need a
superhero thing okay hold up I never
said they need I never said okay I might
have put that in the thumbnail for for
thumbnail purposes okay but I've never
openly come out and said they need it I
said it would be a very good thing to
have because you know let's not act like
they ain't getting they ain't getting
Wolverine spot okay we're not doing that
okay we're reversing that because me and
DT will go back and forth for like 10
minutes over this just word need I was
not against having the superhero game of
course not but need I get it yeah so
the go ahead yeah so I I I just
personally look at the chat flaming me
add it Captain he said they need it all
the
time need on a thumbnail big white
letters need I I do think that I I said
they need it if they if they okay so no
no okay stop it chat stop it look what
you're doing trying you're trying to
derail the podcast on purpose
chat
I'm on to you I know what you're doing
and it's not going to work we're going
back to talk about quor on Xbox so I
just personally feel like coutur would
be a fantastic G even if they have to go
back and they have to rework it find a
new studio to remake it as long as they
can make that agreement with Disney I
think it would be very beneficial for
Xbox I so is it so CT F first off I I
completely agree with both of you I
think if they find the right developer
why not right it's a huge IP
um man Phil Spencer in the team is it
I'm just going to Pivot a small bit here
but Phil Spencer and the team have been
on the ball lately don't you find like
there there's not only are they
snatching really good Indies for Game
Pass not like Spirit T and other games
like that are just gems right in the
rough um they're really stepping away
from things that might be uh trouble
like for instance this I'm sure they saw
it or heard about it and they looked at
it and they're like you know what they
could have it you know what they could
have it let's see what happens they're
going to fail and we we find another
Studio to do it properly you know theyve
seen on the ball imagine having
PlayStation to come play test the game
that they're funding or you know helping
fund and then they not only are they
dissatisfied they're like pull the club
pull the plug pull the plug like imagine
like imagine them going home later on
you you find out that not only
PlayStation was dissatisfied they are no
longer funding this
project I I think hate to be that I
think it I think they're stepping away
like it's clear right they're probably
stepping away from easily easily like
like adex said when they private all of
those YouTube videos with the trailer
you know they tried to use the excuse of
what music like or like music license or
something like that play the Star Wars
music like bro come on everybody knew
the writing was on the wall when they
removed all of those or they privated
all of those videos from the trailer so
I think so many podcast so many Sony
podcasts were like no it's normal don't
worry it's all good n it's all good nah
you know this game is bro I mean look I
don't I don't want to start bashing
PlayStation but I mean let's be real man
they had a few yeah you do I do too you
know what I mean my man my man I got to
get you on my show man we we can talk a
lot of TR
I'm ready I'm
ready uh but you know it seems like
they've had a few games um third party
games like you know maybe this game um
deviation game which they're not owned
by Sony but they were a partner um seems
like something's going on there and they
you know they has some stuff that maybe
people should be asking a question is
something going on over there but you
know I know people want to focus on
console sales and nothing else so I
guess everything but we don't do that
that D we we we make it very we make it
our what's what they call mission
statement we make it our mission
statement to inform you that there are
certain rooms in I'm not saying the
whole PlayStation Mansion is burning
down but there's definitely some suckers
in them that's on fire okay you know
this is like one of those scenarios
where they're in the living room and
they sitting there watching TVC in the
smoke and they're like we're not calling
the fire department yet everything's
okay everything's okay no it ain't
so yeah know like Sony Sony right now
honestly I I talked about this really
briefly in the iron Lords podcast you
should go check it out you know what I
mean um but um the other two competitors
are very nostalgic right like Sony has
some nostalgia in Japan and and has
Their audience right uh um Nintendo
obviously is the most nostalgic company
Xbox came in late and to grow themselves
they really tried hard to like you know
they really tried big with the Xbox 360
right at a certain point though right if
if they were any smaller of a company
their mess up in the Xbox One era would
probably killed them right if they were
like if they were Sony and and and Sony
was like had no Nostalgia right and they
came in and they flopped so hard against
a nostalgic player like Nintendo let's
say they would never recover they would
probably have bailed out after the uh
after a failure right they kind of 100%
theyve they imagine PlayStation 3 had a
gigantic fan base and that was the only
reason why they could like they had the
PS2 to to back them up and all that love
they had with that console and when they
flopped against the 360 they were able
to come back at the end of the
generation blah blah blah blah blah we
know the the history but like companies
like like Sony can't can't mess up right
and Xbox right now is just they have to
watch out cuz they have sheer power and
Longevity on their side know they they
have a double down on money right now
and now they could actually start
building on the Nostalgia Xbox 360 would
have been a great step for them if they
didn't mess up so hard on the Next
Generation cuz they that's what we are
right we're that generation we're the
360 guys that stuck up all the way
through the bad right and then that's no
algia took us Halo all that stuff right
Skyrim
Bethesda carried us over and and really
kept him alive and and PlayStation's
going to watch out they don't really
have a Call of Duty or big nostalgic
character they like to think Kratos is
that character but he's not he's not
he's not Mario he's not Mario Kart
selling 58 million um he's not he's he's
not Minecraft selling 300 million he's
not any of that stuff he's not GTA right
that Sony wishes they need that right
now their only
hope which I I find funny is that
Spider-Man right Spider-Man is like that
one nostalgic character that they might
take and try to build and it's so funny
that it's not even their IP anyways I
gotta get guy on
wbd I like his style yeah here's the
thing when it comes to that I think you
can actually argue a good argument too
that Master Chief
iconically is more iconic
Thanos yep I I I totally agree but
that's my point is that like if they had
such a they kept their strong fan base
throughout 360 and they entered that new
that new Xbox One era as game focused
they have their Nostalgia they keep on
with the first party you know third
party buyout or whatever grab as much
people as you can they could really
leverage their lead but they they
completely fumbled right and Playstation
with all that Nostalgia all that backing
came back and was able to to take the
crown again right let's not you know
fumble around the ball they really did
take back Their audience I see hip hop
gamer in the chat what's up brother
um I'm going to keep it
simple Halloween was obviously a few
weeks ago hip hop you want in tell me I
S I've seen I've seen
kids wearing Mario costumes Luigi I saw
a couple Minecrafts I even seen five
night at Freddy and I seen Master Chief
I saw two Master Chief costumes this
year um all I'm trying to say is Kratos
is a monster of a
franchise is God of War a billion dollar
franchise
yet no no okay okay thank
you no further questions
johon here's my thing when it comes to
that you know what I'm I'm sorry I'm
sorry addict hold on because that that
was directed at me so I just got to say
one thing first
off stop pretending that
Kratos didn't
murder every single IP in the three like
in any era it came out except for you
know Xbox one even Xbox One when it was
at its lowest blew up release right can
we agree on that mhm okay Kratos at his
biggest rate now still sold slower than
Xbox uh than Halo at its weakest in the
Xbox One era can we agree on that it did
right so let's not
pretend that the I don't
know what what's the franchise at 100
million games now I don't even know
combined in all of the franch
let's not pretend that's a small number
let's let's not do that I love Kos I
love Kos is amazing Halo has movies
books games TV shows why isn't there
Kratos TV show hip-hop oh may you might
make him upset if if it was so
widespread I feel like they' have done
made that by now that's like the easiest
s in the world killing all the BS that's
you know what I think it is
I think they're trying to compare Halo
now to what Halo uh is you know they're
trying toare what Halo is now to Kratos
what krle is now and you have about the
entire you know what I'm saying because
think about it bro I'mma tell you right
now I worked at GameStop part time I
will never experience anything like Halo
3 Midnight launch let me tell you nope
the midnight launch of Halo 3 I've never
experienced anything like that gaming
related this was a small GameStop in
Taylor Michigan I was working at and the
line was bro you would not believe this
is just one small GameStop the line was
like around the corner just for Halo 3
we are not saying God of War isn't a an
amazing franchise I love bro I love God
of War
personally it's just
that you can't say that I mean it's
everybody's opinion but the facts is
that Halo is a billion doll franchise
billion with a
B BBB and I don't even think you have to
go bilding I'm willing to bet you that
if you
took a picture of Kratos and a
picture of of Chief and went around more
people gonna recognize Chief than M than
Kratos Nixie is still see but you're
saying you're talking about Halo
infinite you talking about comparing God
War today to Halo today yes yes my f uh
my brother's friends here I'mma ask them
I'mma ask their opinion on this continue
though no I'm just saying what what
games games we brought up I thought you
know it's all subjective right but the
facts is the facts God of War is a very
big franchise huge franchise I love God
of War personally and I'm an xbot I love
like God of War I was amazing God of War
28 thing absolutely amazing but what who
the more popular character who which one
is a billion doll franchise we're
talking about the entire franchise not
just Halo infinite versus God of War
Ragnarok see that's what y'all are
trying trying trying to compare is Halo
what it was like what it was in in in
early 2000s absolutely not it's not I
bet
you I'm sorry go I bet you there's more
upset ex-girlfriends and girlfriends
because they because their boyfriends is
playing Master playing Halo than there
will ever be
of them playing God of War they don't
even know what that is like a lot like
look I'm not saying Kratos isn't a
strong individual person and he's
relevant in the industry there's a
difference between being relevant in the
gaming industry and being relevant in
mainstream a lot of people know who
Kratos is in and out of mainstream and
the gaming industry but I'm willing to
bet you there's more people that know
who Master Chief is in the mainstream
than than than katos see I don't like
the response though when James Lee said
what he said stop what you what oh how
dare you say that about about Kratos he
Halo ain't no Kratos dog stop and chill
out man shut up man I hear that [__]
yeah bring it bring it I love it I love
it he's wrong so I I love it even
more how big Halo 3 was how big that
Halo
franchise I sent you uh an invite so you
know if you really want uh definitely
come out okay let me blind rod
I'm out love you addict but addict sour
cream spoiled this BR what are you
talking about what that what does that
mean I know like do I need a like a
dictionary what's that thing Urban
Dictionary is that what they call that
where you look up like slaying and stuff
do I need that to just like I feel like
that that that that's a puzzle like I
feel like I have to decipher
that like it's just like look like I get
it man here's my thing these are my
opinions I I'm an influencer and a
podcaster only thing I can tell you is
my opinions now if you get upset by that
cool I I don't know what to tell you
because guess what I ain't gonna I I'm
not gonna miss beat I'm gonna roast you
a little bit in the chat but that's
about all it's just like stop it with
this I'm tired of this everyone wanting
a hive mind mindset everyone wants
everyone's mindset to be the exact same
thing and then God forbid dirt that you
have an in political opinion because
then it goes from I want you to think
what I want you what I think to you
don't think what I think so I'mma get
you cancelled I'mma get I'mma get your
sponsorships tooken out it's like let's
let's stop all this stuff man like
people have different opinions this is
video games it ain't that serious
man yeah and he paid you money to say
that which is ridiculous you know what I
mean no he didn't Super Chat that a just
I just highlight it would have been
beautiful wouldn't it yeah I got no
issue but it's it's just crazy man no no
but but in all honesty guys Chad look
I'm I sometimes maybe I'm aggressive on
the words uh I love PlayStation and hate
them the only reason why I hate on
Playstation is because they went in the
Direction with games that I don't like I
like the old school God of Wars right I
love God of Wars I love the old school
God of Wars they made it bigger than
they um than it was right they Chang the
whole formula and to to kind of suit the
rest of their portfolio I don't like
that I don't like the controller I don't
like some of their decisions right I'm a
Canadian um I I love Western
storytelling you know I love God of War
I love all this stuff
but but I could hate on it too I I just
and I could be real and say Halo
Halo is bigger
way bigger than God of War ever
was yeah period it's just the
truth the truth what's funny is I think
you can argue that Peak got a war maybe
to to the hardcore but a lot of people
don't even know when Pete God of War was
was it during the God of War 3 era was
it during the the 2018 era was it during
ragnok era like we don't even know when
Pete God of War
was p Peak God of War you know dirt how
about you I think I think God of War 3
right God of War 3 was incredible yeah I
think I think God of War I was was Peak
Peak Peak Peak I
think as far as popularity though was it
maybe I don't know I don't know about
the sales let me see let me look at 20
well 2018 for sure right now has the
highest sales number right that's what
I'm thinking let me let me Google it so
like to me man at the end of the day it
it's it's just about what what's your
flavor what kind of games you like yeah
to to me look God of War 3 in my
opinion is the best action adventure
game ever
made like ever made like there's nothing
that even remotely comes close to that
thing like like what's funny is I think
it's better than the last of us Last of
Us Part Two it like that is it's a video
game it's a big old video definition of
a video game and people like all this
and that like yo spoiler alert but you
know this game came out like a decade
ago you killed Poseidon the first 30
minutes of the game and it's not Wasing
incredible what an incredible what an
incredible game all right
um it looks like from from a sales
standpoint 2018 sold the best yeah uh un
understandable because it's out the most
it's had like a lot of black Fridays
already you know what I mean so um and
it has a PC release so I'm not I'm not
um yeah I'm not suris part one sold 4.6
million Part Two Sold
4.2 chain of el that was on the V right
yeah goad see okay see so when I say
that Halo was bigger or is a bigger icon
or than God of War can you repeat those
numbers and then go look at any Halo
game even now even even infinite
infinite right now probably has way more
players in all the all three combined
all three yes they're 30 million players
now for infinite but yeah said God of
War one sold 4.6 million God of War I so
4.2 God of War chain of Olympus that was
a vaita title right that was actually
pretty good I remember that um sold 3.2
God of War Three sold
7.6 go to Sparta was another Vita title
1.1 now I remember God of War ascension
kind of was uh it that one didn't do it
well yeah that only sold three million
and then in 2018 it says so 23 million
the god or rling right right now was
like at 11
million
so and and compared to Halo
123 uh or four even um let's see since
you guys like to like compare popularity
right and compare numbers sheer numbers
sold or whatever you want to compare
even though free to playay makes Halo
infinite bigger than all three of them
combined like I said let me see but
let's just go with the sales numbers if
you want yeah let me bring it up um it's
not going to be very good for
them I'm pretty sure but something
popped up to say Halo has what the
franchise has sold over 81 million let
me yeah try to go to the individual
games and I'm will to bet you like 10 to
15 is just Halo
3 uh yeah I'm pretty sure five was 10
million five okay okay so part one sold
5.5 million Part Two Sold
8.4 yep part three 14 Halo Wars which is
a real time strategy sold
2.6 ODST Halo 3 ODST sold 6.5 Halo re
sold
9.8 Halo listen Halo Combat Evol
anniversary which was just a remaster of
Halo 1 so
2.4 Halo 4 so 9.7 yeah Hal Halo Master
Chief so
8.1 Halo 5 Guardian so 9.5 look at that
okay pause pause pause
9.5 for Halo 5 in
thex the worst the worst one the worst
game in the worst time period guys stop
it
stop so yeah Halo Wars 2 so 2.2 million
since you like bringing up numbers I'm
bringing up numbers well he's bringing
up numbers because he's amazing but also
Halo infinite is also very big we like
to pretend that it's not but it is it
was it was
big yep
so sorry I know that derailed the whole
thing there but but but it's true it's
like you know people look I know we went
on a long you know we don't we ain't
going to go on this too much but it's
just like to me personally just my
opinion if you asked 300 people on each
side and you show them a picture of
Kratos and you show them a picture of
Master Chief uh I'm willing to bet you
not by name but more people are going to
know the figure of of of Master Chiefs
than they would Kratos now obviously are
there going to be people that know both
yeah but I'm willing to bet you there's
going to be people more people that know
what Master Chief is and mention like
even smaller audiences you know Kratos
and master chief are both in
fortnite so it's just it's just crazy
man people
want and you know what's the craziest
thing what's the craziest thing is
like if
you you know what I'm not I'm not going
to say it you know what continue
continue at it it's all good yeah now I
see a guy Prince green he's said well
the God of War 2018 sold more than Halos
individually bro I'm pretty sure we
would talk about the franchise as a
whole and not to mention a few you know
there's a lot of factors that go into
that but you know let's let's go into
something that I know you hater is in
the chat don't like apparently the sales
I think it's just in Europe right now U
yeah you know of Xbox U you know it's
been been on the decline and you know I
just want your guys as over our opinion
know we'll start with dirt on this one
you know what is your mindset when you
see the cell for you know Xbox and you
know the the UK area that's not even
meeting I think it said not even the
original Xbox yeah well well like first
off um I'm sure Xbox wants to do better
over there in Europe um but it's no
secret that Europe prefers PlayStation
and that's fine um XBox I'm sure they
want to do better over there man um
PlayStation the the casuals has chosen
the PlayStation 5 just like they chose
the PS4 and Xbox has a lot of work to do
to try to get some of that mind share
back I mean they might not ever be able
to because they lost a lot in Xbox 360
generation to the Xbox One transition
they lost a lot of of that mind share
that market share from from PlayStation
I mean to PlayStation 4 because of some
of the mistakes the Xbox One made so
even Phil sprin mentioned they lost the
worst generation to lose last generation
with a lot of digital content and things
of that nature so they have a lot of
work um to do console sales obviously
don't mean as much as they used to right
especially for Xbox it might still means
a lot for PlayStation because to buy
software on Playstation you pretty much
have to have a PS5 with Xbox to play
software that's made by Xbox you don't
necessarily have to have an Xbox console
but I'm sure they do want to sell more
consoles in Europe but you know it is
what it is I'm sure they're they're fine
uh financially they're fine they're
doing extreme well um like I said
consoles don't mean as much as it used
to it still matters don't get me wrong
conso sales definitely still matter I'm
not going to go ahead and say they don't
matter at all no they matter um and and
they want to do better and it's gonna
take time you know Xbox had to pretty
much re reboot rebuild the brand Phil
Spencer and his team had to rebuild the
brand and they've they're doing a
tremendous job at this point but it's
still G to take time they still gota you
know convince other people or they have
to try to get some people to give Xbox a
try and right now that's that really
that's really not happening in Europe
but we'll see what happens in the future
though yeah let me uh grab these super
chats real quick I apologize forgot all
about it trying to get this uh
conversation going man we got the $5 for
the angry therapist Happy Thanksgiving I
made it to the one uh to this one on
time appreciate it man you know you guys
always in there being supportive got
over four 400 people in the chat man hit
that like button if you guys enjoying
the content we got a $2 Super Chat from
Joe Dunmore yeah Sony ain't got no money
you know I wouldn't say they ain't got
no money but they ain't they definitely
don't have the money that they want they
have less they have less yeah I would
say significantly less but we gonna keep
going we had a $2 super trap from the
angry th person is like listen here we
broke yeah what's funny is they go if
they lose his lawsuit we about talk
about it could be even less broke bro we
got a $2 Super Chat for Nintendo d the
ataku AOW is finishing up the team will
be free I think he's
refering yeah cure I think that they
made part two right yeah they made part
two and I think they would do a
phenomenal job making part one um but
part of me is just like if they're
willing to make it yeah I just don't
want to push nothing on them you know
what I'm saying I I feel like a being
contracted Contracting another team
they'll be more
financially up to taking it than pushing
on a current team that that worked for
their for their game you know right now
you got the avow team I assume that some
of them are going to shift over if not
already shift over to the outer Worlds 2
because I assume avow is coming to the
close of its development cycle and to me
if they want to continue making AOW
content or you know push in that
direction I would want them to get the
ability to but if they want to make uh
you know I I would say you know New
Vegas 2 because I think they would be a
little bit more open to making something
like that even something like you know
Star Wars old republic too they made
that one and I thought that was a
fantastic game I just want them to be
more open to getting to do it they want
to do I don't want no you know you going
do because I tell you to you don't got
no choice I say what we make like I
don't want none of that going down yeah
and they're they're a big they're
growing too right which is what pretty
exciting and they're talented and
they're I know they're really awesome
yeah then we got a uh we got a$ five
Super Chat for the angry therapist MD
Halo is so big Hollywood blamed it for
their low ticket sales I remember that I
remember when Halo 3 came out it was EI
either part two or part three or maybe
even both the Hollywood box office that
weekend wasn't as great as it was the
previous week or something like that and
I remember they said oh it could be
because the Halo release and things like
that man yeah it was big game it broke a
record like never forget Halo 2 Broke a
record for
entertainment in one in like 24 hours
they made like 200 something million or
something like that I mean Halo is the
reason why consoles blew up in
multiplayer right so 100%
bro anyways why are we even arguing this
I don't understand well cuz people don't
want to hear it man you know they don't
want to hear the TR yeah so you know
okay let's go back to the sales here's
my thing um G I'll let you go ahead and
uh you know get your opinion because I'm
about to go on a rant and uh you know
when I go on a rant I tend to take the
entire ecosystem with me
oh I'm ready I'm yo I'm going to sit
back I got some popcorn I'm I'm ready um
so uh really quick I'm just going to go
really quick like I said before um when
you said Phil Spencer said it was the
worst generation to lose well he's right
because of why he's what he said but
also it was the worst because they they
finally got they got a large number they
overtook the competition that had like
years years of nostalgia behind them
right they took them down they were they
like had the whole industry in a nice
little bear hug right or at least an
equal footing and they completely
slipped they fell on their face mhm and
that that that really hurt them um and
it's rumbling even into this generation
and you know we could see that in the
sales there um when you put out
consistently good games um that helps
build your brand and Sony and Nintendo
have both consistently for decades put
out bangers after Banger right yeah they
missed um but they had name association
with big Brands we can argue Sony wasn't
even a Sony console without square right
at one point it wasn't guys we let's not
forget it wasn't God of War selling
systems it was square enex square enex
was selling systemsi was selling with
metal gear you know ex exactly Konami
their big Japanese relationships were
really
pushing that that that console it wasn't
God of War guys and guess what was
pushing consoles Halo anyways point is
point point is you can see the vibration
happening and and they're really they
they're in this era where they finally
have the full backing of a big parent
company that's willing to do whatever
they want and all they got to do big or
small get those contracts out there get
the small Indies you know that that's
what uh Sony had to do to grab back
Their audience get the Indies get the
stuff like cortor remakes the get get
get anything you can U make Call of Duty
devs uh do other games
experiment pump out those quality games
and after a long while it's going to
take about 5 years but after a long
while when they got their mind share
back Sony's in big trouble guys so it
celebrate this low console sales thing
as much as you can right now because in
five years when when things start to
come out and
overwhelm you bet you better I mean Sony
better have Marvel under the wing
completely but even that doesn't help
them because we see what Disney's going
through so anyways that's all I'm going
to say you better have your Minecraft
you better have your Call of Duty you
better have something cuz Microsoft has
all of that so I don't know it's like
it's like I
said PlayStation would kill to have the
uh the grab of these games as a Services
Minecraft Sea of Thieves uh fallout 7 6
Elder Scrolls Online they would they
would
absolutely love to have those type of
games
100% well yeah yeah those those those
yeah two finish completely those games
are gigantic like if Sony like Sony's
Only Hope right now is to hope to God
they're alive enough for all of this
stuff to I mean blow over and and they
have a they become a Marvel Studio I
don't know but even that does doesn't
help them because like I said Disney is
faing with that IP we we thought that
Disney can't fail and won't die because
they have Marvel on fire but look at
some point you fail you fall and if you
fall enough people are done with you and
that's scary for Sony and also Call of
Duty Call of Duty by the way oh yeah you
can not Call of Duty Call of Duty is
definitely not immune to failings so
they got to watch out with Call of Duty
as well but anyway point is but also but
you can add that to the list um attic of
the games out the service you can add
that Call of Duty to the list now like
war zone you add that to the list Xbox
first party IP know they gota yeah but
Xbox does have to watch out with Call of
Duty I'm going to call that out because
I do think that they have big money with
Candy Crush they have big money with
Call of Duty they have big money with
World of Warcraft all that stuff is good
but if you consistently put out fives
there's a problem and that that might
diminish you just like Disney it might
have diminishing returns it might slowly
burn burn you down you know so don't
worry about that it'll be all good yeah
I hope not I hope
not okay Addy what's on your mind
brother
okay let me let me go to solo actually
let me just do this
one Xbox sales are down
because they just don't have the games
right now you know they have games but I
feel
like last year it was very
underwhelming this year there's been
good games such as Starfield but I I
think we can agree that Starfield is one
of those you play to feel quality you
don't see to see quality you know and
unfortunately you know you look at
something like you know a god of war and
stuff like you you see those games and
you see quality because of the graphics
that's not going to be the what's what
I'm looking for the quota going forward
because now it's just G I feel
like Microsoft is and Xbox have like
this this gear this machine going that's
going to constantly shoot out a game
every three months and when you're
consistently seeing them in the news and
consistently seeing their game show up
there as long as they're good obviously
I think we can all agree if if these
games aren't good then all this is out
the window but I I don't think you're
gonna have more of these hit than not
hit I do agree I do believe that and I
feel like look like last year didn't
really hype a whole lot of people up it
wasn't really a lot that came out last
year this year there was stuff going on
there but it wasn't like crazy besides
like Starfield but next year you're
gonna have all the the the all the ABK
games going in the The Game Pass you're
going to have talks about Call of Duty
going into the Game Pass then guess what
you're going to have you're going to
have a vow dropping in Game Pass
hellblade dropp it in game plan most
likely you're gonna see stuff on Indiana
Jones and it even might come out next
year then what you're G to start hearing
more and more conversation about oh this
is going on this is going on then you're
you're you're a little bit more in the
mainstream look one of the biggest
issues is Microsoft didn't really have
the prod and I felt like a lot of this
was designed for around this time in
like last year but the pandemic skipped
a lot of it the pandemic put it to where
a lot of their initial plans was delayed
a while because it it delayed everything
at least six months to year and now
we're at that end of that six months
two-year delay and we're we're seeing I
I think you're about to start seeing
what's going on like as perfect dark
Fable gear six out of Worlds 2 Call of
Duty whatever the hell ABK is working on
because we don't know obsidian remake
Fallout 3 remake what else man People
Help Me Help Me Like disorder to so much
that's why doom and people say every
year they say 2022 wait till 2021
look look
Nixie I want you to I want you to
revisit me next year this is 11 2022
because this is the last year I say that
[__] okay next year you might not even
be in the chat you're going to change
your name and become an Xbox
Fanboy that's what's happening to you
next year because I I personally see
Doom a doom prequel what do you guys
think's gonna happen when these games
start dropping because what's funny is
you be acting like they made these games
individually in the moment Microsoft
takes off of More Money More Talent
they're just going to start making dog
[__] games it's not the case that's not
how it works
um you know what you're right and and
and guys in the chat you know I see it
on Twitter too right you know oh it's
always wait till next year wait till
next year guys
Microsoft is it Microsoft can afford to
be like hey wait next year wait next
year wait next year and guess what guys
guess what guess
what when that one magic
comes they're going to blow your socks
off and they're going to stay they're
here to stay guys they ain't going away
so at one point they're going to come in
with a Floodgate of things and lovely
IPS my God what happens when blizzard
starts to kick in right what happens
when blizzard starts to kick in because
every every every single Blizzard game
is a cult hit like a cult hit right
every single one people sit there I I've
said this over people sit there and say
oh this what happens when that happens
what happens when elder scroll 6 starts
seeing gamep Play you start seeing
actual stuff happening with this game
you start seeing where it is and you
know I think that's probably Todd
Howard's last game and he going out
there and say it just works I know that
was really bad take
but can can I actually just add one
thing look um in the 360 era right they
had Bethesda in their wing
right they had Bethesda in their wing uh
people Associated Bethesda games with
Xbox they also Associated uh Call of
Duty with Xbox heavily they Associated
Halo
right what did they just grabbed guys
they grabbed the holy Duo plus extra
yeah to their front line from when they
beat their ass sorry when they beat them
when they beat PlayStation that's the
studios that helped them do it both of
them all of them and they're all under
Xbox and you think that nothing's going
to change once people see Diablo content
consistently Warcraft content
consistently any Bethesda game I mean
Doom yeah maybe they're not hot right
now but Doom has never really missed
Wolfenstein everything guys they have
all those hits and all Sony has is
becoming Marvel dreams Marvel studio all
right you could have that you could have
the Marvel studio and ask Disney how
that's working out for them add it Gams
Ley they have
remasters oh yeah sorry Last of Us Part
Two uh by the time we get a Last of Us
Part three they're ready to show us Last
of Us Part One H how much did they how
how much did that dude oh where did that
the hell happen he died all right well
hi I'm your white guy for this this
evening so um go what the hell happened
to the attic oh there you go he's back
accidentally left yeah I don't know how
I got thing yeah Sor what it was is like
I was moving my cat and I and I didn't
know personing exit would kick us out
thank God that we will stream yards I'm
about to talk to S we about to just make
this official I'm about to just tie the
knot with with streamyard we about to
get the logo thing up on here because
you know uh first I don't like seeing
that little duck in the top right yeah
you got to pay to get him rid
of extremely easy to use bro I tell you
I like it just because like situations
like that where I accidentally left that
would have been on OBS is a rat like we
got to start stream over again show over
you gave me a heart attack I was about
to take over you know in in my in my
story though I was sniped by PlayStation
assassins 100%
hey mean your story right the only thing
with stream y' you can't like um you
have to use OBS if you're going on watch
like you know like a E3 or something
because streamyard does not do well
unless you use Excuse me unless you use
OBS with streamyard because it doesn't
do well with um streaming stuff on the
web it's always choppy because I tried
to do it before and I realized you know
what I'm have to go to OBS for um you
know like when I stream E3 but yeah man
you guys are um man this is this is
crazy but you guys right like what were
we talking about we talking about I
don't know before the the PlayStation
assassination showed up to my house I
ain't going even lie to you man they
pulled up right here in front of me and
like you goonna get off of that stream
right
now that guy that was mad at you before
it came out it's like don't hit me with
the water I'm
s well hey let me say this right quick
because I see like the chat is really
like naming games that Xbox has
announced look man PlayStation um you
know they're they're at a point where I
think Jim Ryan really kind of screwed
them up a little bit um he wanted to do
strictly games as a
service and I think he he uh hired
Bungie he bought a couple of Studios
that's doing games as a service and I
just don't know if it's going to work um
because you know like Xbox has a few
games as a service already that's
successful but there's so many games as
a service that has tried to be success
out here that some of them just failed
miserably and when you're a a publisher
known for quality single player games
when you ask your main Studio one of
your best Studios naughty dog to do a
games as a service I know they had to
piss them off yeah well it it pissed
them off royally because they can't even
get their freaking characters to jump
correctly meanwhile this this elf this
elf in a green suit you know climbing
mountains and jumping off with
parachutes and stuff and diving into
Caverns meanwhile the God of War can't
even put his kid 3 feet up I can't I
can't do it man damn hey this guy I
can't do it hey this guy I like here
kills
me help me please PlayStation um they're
they're still a a huge brand and Xbox
still has some catching up to do as far
as console sales go but I just want
people to understand that even though
PlayStation is winning console sales
this is not the same Xbox from the Xbox
one generation I think that's obvious at
this point this is obvious you know some
of the guys in the chat Mike Johnson
Nixie some of you guys I understand you
guys you're being cautious because you
you see what's happening but you don't
want to go out there and say PlayStation
needs to do this PlayStation needs to do
that because you know it's not going to
happen so hold on to the console sales
narrative as long as you can as long as
you know that it's possible Xbox will
out money
PlayStation especially now they got ABK
yes ABK is on Xbox y'all can say that's
not organic all you want it is what it
is Xbox had the capital they bought them
have to deal with it kind of is kind of
is right though dirt because I
mean for for a long time when Xbox was
coming up everybody was like oh look at
this platform it's only the shooter
platform you got Gears of War you got
Halo and Call of Duty those you got it's
like well you've been name associating
Call of Duty and and all these American
companies rightfully so to Microsoft
rightfully so and that's that yeah
that's that they've been working
together for decades
Bethesda worked with Xbox for a very
long time and they helped like I said
helped them beat PlayStation that decade
that generation so I don't know I don't
know what else to tell you guys you're
lying to yourselves if you if you think
anything else 100% man 100% um so yeah
so like Nixie PlayStation ain't perfect
Xbox is not perfect either bro neither
is Nintendo but it's competition and me
personally I'm I'm glad to see Xbox
competing how some some of you some of
the PlayStation guys said last
generation is Xbox going to compete
please compete and that's what they're
doing man but next year is going to be
fun I'm sure PlayStation has some games
they're going to announce at at E3 Andy
let me say this one thing about the Halo
talk that we were just talking about
like what you brought up gamy games Le
um remember Kill
Zone why did PlayStation make that game
no I don't what wasn't there wasn't
there actual like devs that refer it to
as I quote the Halo killer oh yeah that
Killzone was their answer to Halo
remember that they knew Halo was such a
monster they tried to make their own
halo with kill then they made this
redhead girl with a with Dinosaurs Tred
to become an elf and it didn't work cuz
the elfes still kicked her ass um but
anyways uh
whatever hey Addie this is a bot bot
podcast today
brother no I I truly honestly I'm
talking a lot of crap but I it's because
I'm I I love getting people sparked up
against me I love that I love that smoke
guys you can't you can't you can't you
can't me um I I actually love
PlayStation I love PlayStation a lot I
actually loved Horizon the first one the
first horizon was awesome but it got
overshadowed by breath of the wild which
is you
know the better game but anyways um I
love it so don't don't hate me too much
I love it
funny yeah it's just you know let me get
these super chats real quick uh we guys
have been very generous today let me um
all right so we got $5 Super Chat from
JD gamer okay okay first off JD you in
the chat please tell me you post that
Twitter JD did some very very very spicy
stuff today and it was he recorded it
and it was I don't know if he posted on
Twitter but I'm curious he has I'm not
gonna say it because it's his it's his
decision to to say it or not but it was
funny man you know I had gaming Forte
call me and I know when Forte calls me
something going on but we we we get into
this all right so let's start this um
XBox has M okay let me make sure yeah
okay Final Super from JD gamer Xbox
needs mind share and it's not that hard
for them to get it all they need to do
is get the following games exclusive
GTA6 FIFA uh fc24 I don't know what that
is you guys know what that is
fc24 uh yeah yeah that's FIFA yeah
that's they call call FIFA now it's fc24
and Call of
Duty that that' be a lot brother I don't
know if that I don't think they can
legally make Call of Duty uh at least
for 10 years Nintendo d talk with the $5
Super Chat x uh Halo 5 sold 10 million
with an install base of 44 million it's
been on PC God of War 2018 sold 23
million with an install base of
125 million it's got a good point there
man you know you halo Halo kicking it
Halo kicking it man we got a $2 Super
Chat from Aztec warrior going dark Halo
bought your fam homies to play split
screen facts facts $ five Super Chat
from JD gamer mind share is everything
okay I think I can actually when I left
I lost all of the like the little
pinning pinnable Super Chat stuff oh you
did yeah but I think I can
actually show some of it now because I
like when not star I like they they like
they still should be Stars shouldn't
they no uh they when I came back they
were all gone oh F Super Chat from JD
gamer my Shar and everything do the big
thing Xbox and let the haters hate while
taking the casuals to your platform and
that GTA 6 FIFA and then uh rip
PlayStation yo JD he he being real messy
man he being real messy tweet you was
talking about too by the way with with
this is this is him in GameStop sitting
game yeah $10 Super Chat from JD gamer
for those saying halil isn't and can't
be what it was before I say yeah it can
at least to a certain degree it's uh
it's on the up right now and it just
needs more campaign content in Halo 5
type marketing um I think if it had a
giant expansion with more story content
you get a lot more people playing it
story content is important
people need a reason to give it another
opportunity we got to fight all Super
Chat from the angry therapist and D what
happened to the super secret
shook y remember we heard that we heard
that this year so many times yo they
they held stuff back
in add it the homie Jrock posted y'all
boy on on on iron Lords one day saying
they're gonna have another showcase
later this year was was it damn right he
was on you guys show saying there's
going to be another showcase later this
year I mean there's still like a month
and a half left so come on you know what
a you never know you never know dirt you
never
know hey hey they had a couple Indie
ones maybe that's what they were talking
about yeah maybe I don't know what
happened to Sony holding back to the ABK
deal is is over what happened we just
talked about that I read half of it just
lost my mind you you didn't hear they're
too busy buying GTA six apparently I
don't know oh that would be crazy if
they did were able to achieve something
like that no there's no way $10 Super
Chat from JD gamer Xbox has the
following games launching in Game Pass
Halo Cod Doom Quake Persona Crash
Bandicoot Spyro Forza hellblade Elder
Scrolls Fallout all they need is GTA 6
uh FC uh I guess the FIFA and the middle
Gear Solid 5 exclusive yo you don't even
need the other stuff did you just hear
what I read bro Halo C Doom Quake
Persona Crash Bandicoot spiral Forza
hellblade scoll Fallout most of those
games actually are launching most game
Xbox yeah most games Xbox on bro most of
them yeah yeah if they buy
Sega right oh man like I mean you know
GTA 6 I'm going to I'm going to say
something right now which is probably
impossible but like okay seeing how much
uh money uh Google shoots at Apple to be
like the default search engine or
whatever in apple stuff um seeing the
billions by the way of dollars that they
do every year for that is nuts I would
not mind like if I'm Xbox why do I care
dude shoot shoot billions to put GTA 6
for at least in Game Pass don't buy
rights of exclusivity just put it in
Game Pass like I
same day and be like look we'll we'll
give you the dev cost put in Game Pass
for six months put in Game Pass for six
months see what happens J JD gamer
recommended he said I could play it live
can you guys see
it I was told about this foolishness
over the phone and I haven't I haven't
watched it because I've been prepping
for the show so we're all going to watch
this together for the first time well
some of you seen it act like you ain't
seen it okay don't don't spoil it for
everyone I'm watching you okay let's go
can you guys hear
it y oh here we go okay hold is a little
low yeah graphics better games better
console a gota worry about
overheating say that one more time one
more
time listen
listen
[Laughter]
oh man I love it I love it that's
funny yeah by the way uh Lord Lord
Metroid I wasn't saying like exclusive
no don't buy exclusive rights no no no
no I said Put it six months billions of
dollar billions of dollars don't care
put that in Game Pass that's going to
Skyrocket something I'm telling you that
will Skyrocket get subs in a second that
game has like 190 million players man
190 million if you just say here's your
Dev cost put it for three months even I
don't care uh you're growing your
subs G like especially it's a social
game in game pass on PC I don't know man
that would that would that would that
would kill better games better games
better games better
game oh my God I needed that laugh I
need that laugh all right we let's we ah
we got 15 minutes I Tred to be out of
here by seven but we have another person
on today so I mean I'm not really gonna
put yeah I'm I'm sorry about that guys
don't don't apologize don't apologize um
let's talk about this PlayStation lot
soon I have a feeling this is GNA be
even dirt not dirty it's gonna be even
more messy all right I'm I'm filling in
the uh the time stamp police you know
don't don't come after me all right
so PlayStation's being
sued apparently does anyone know the
actual context behind
this um it seems that from what I read
um PlayStation is being sued because uh
I guess people are saying they the only
way way that you can buy digital
PlayStation content is on the
PlayStation store they don't allow you
to buy any digital PlayStation content
out side of the PlayStation store since
2019 or something help me out for people
in the chat if I'm wrong um like Xbox
allows you to buy digital games at
GameStop or Best Buy or wherever else
Amazon but Playstation only allows it at
the PlayStation store so that's I put I
put in the chat the Tweet to uh that
that uh the Tweet we just reacted to
guys go over there and like that
Masterpiece man that Master better games
better I might even make that off a too
kind of funny better gam better games
and I love what he said you don't got to
worry about overheating
either so you know he just played he
just what R returno overheated and
turned off Spider-Man overheated and
turned off like there was quite a bit
that that was going down so let let's
let's go over so pretty much they're
being sued for a variety things but it
seems like the key factor is because
they're not allowing more options for
for their
100% yeah and um hey hey yo Mike Johnson
Hey listen I know you guys love the CMA
when they blocked the damn deal you hate
him now though huh when CMA told him go
go ahead with this lawsuit now you now
you mad I mad at the C now 2027 is near
HJ du yeah okay y'all still talking
about
2027 whatever works for y'all man
whatever works for y'all you know I keep
seeing this guy on playst might
is this this guy jdb guy is he's
PlayStation Centric well honestly this
isn't the real jdb actually this with
the real J dub please stand up yeah it's
not okay I was I was G I was going to
talk trash but uh continue add it back
to you that's that's not the real J yeah
so here you know when it comes down to
this is like
man like it PlayStation
continues to be focused on everything
else and and you know let's focus let's
redirect the focus on the PlayStation
people they continue to focus on Xbox
and talk about Xbox 247 and they own
damn house is burning down to the ground
100% like I feel like every week it's
it's more and more negative news on on
Xbox like consistently constantly and it
feels like you know for the most part
people act like it doesn't happen you
know people people want you to be
focused on what they're doing and and
you're like look like you're l
house is is on fire right now you know
and I get it people people
are are so I I think it's about a lot
about monetary value and a lot about
laziness I feel like a lot of these
people don't want to to make the kind of
content okay because I feel like some of
them they want to be tooken seriously
but then they get on that that hype
thing on talking [__] about Xbox and
they see those views and they don't want
to divert from that they they want to
continue to stay on that path say
look unless you do it classy which you
know I would say like Alex does it
classy I I think I think Dart you do
your console war stuff classy like
people eventually change drave off of
that well I wouldn't say it's classy but
you know but but I'm saying you're never
disrespectful like you make jokes
notless they disrespect me me yeah and
being very look I love how these
PlayStation people they just come in
here it is what it is man because you in
here not the other way around I ain't in
your show watching you in my show
watching what you guys PlayStation
podcasts no because they're all anti
Xbox
podcasts true the the I'm not classy I
wouldn't say I'm
classy I guys say I'm classy I wouldn't
say I'm we got we need some dirt's
classy in the chat man got some classy
dirt I definitely wouldn't say I'm
classy I can disagree with you on that
one add I'll be I'll be going after
these dudes man see AA Troy ad like I
love watching dirt but no I'm a echo CH
I'm when adct when adct said that dirt
was like
this oh well look who's in the chat is
that the real him I don't know why to
worry about house my Gears of War
direction leave Xbox to go to St Monica
are you talking about the one
person they always love to to to to
focus on the one person yeah but they
ignore Jim Ryan and Connie Bo getting
fired yeah let's let's not Let's ignore
like half of naughty dog's management
left and I guess you can always point
the finger like the initiative but the
initiative ain't done nothing nothing
comp it's because learned how to jump
that's why they need expectations on
there Sho without some people you know y
do you guys think that they should be
sued for this for not giving options or
do you think this is you know it's funny
but it's kind of ridiculous at the same
time um if I'll go okay um me personally
I honestly I don't care about this
lawsuit I'm not going to really cover it
unless they lose then that [__] would be
funny y I I was talking I was talking to
King and I was like what's funny is they
they had the
ability to be able to do the right thing
and now they didn't and now if they lose
this which I don't think they're going
to lose but if they lose this they could
have used that money and bought a
publisher like they've been wanting to
do like did you hear there they hired a
lawyer that was uh that worked for Xbox
during the ABK trial one of those
lawyers over there I'm sure they I'm
sure they having nightmares over that
yeah but I'm surpr honestly I'm
surprised it's allowed to go to trial
because usually when you hear about
cases like this it's never allowed to go
to trial like with those guys that was
trying to sue x Xbox over the ABK deal
but
apparently there's something there you
know that is allowed to go to trial so
we'll see what happens man but honestly
I don't I don't give a damn neither do I
unless they lose and and like I said
they'll be funny how
if they I I don't know how class action
lawsuits will they have to settle for
the whole like five billion or could
they could they settle that down I have
I have if it goes to trial if they lose
noay billion dollar is a lot they pay
they pay whatever is asked if they lose
five
billion they could try to sett out of
court right now they try to sett out of
court like before it goes to trial but
if if they lose this
trial $5
billion is a lot of money for Sony for
for Sony I mean let's be clear for Sony
yeah I mean did didn't play didn't Xbox
and they getting sued by the government
for not paying taxes like missing
tax 28 million shrug it up it went all
right whatever yo what's funny is is
Xbox probably worth more
like what what their supposed tax like I
don't know if if they truly owe those
taxes or not the Xbox supposedly owes
more tax than probably PlayStation has
in cash right now like yeah yeah I'm
pretty sure they did somebody in chat
keep saying they got five
billion um yeah I don't know how true
that is but yeah yeah so I'm going to
I'm going to go next I'm going to make
it quick because I don't actually care
either uh that's a huge sum of money for
Sony and didn't they just pay Des like
Bungie didn't they just pay them just
they were paying they were they were it
was a payment plan for bun it off you
think this could lead to like serious
Financial issues that this goes through
it's it's it's POS well I mean they're
going to cut down for sure well they're
going to cut everything that they're
giving a chance will probably be cut so
everything they're like ah we don't
think but we're going to keep this going
is probably probably going to get cut
that's what my guess would be hey yo um
beer five if it's five billion euros not
dollars 5 billion pounds it's 7.9
billion dollars which 7.9 yeah yeah okay
does PlayStation have the money to pay
that no they no no no no I don't think
so I wonder how much money they got just
chilling like can they pay 7 .5 billion
in
cash it would be that the layoffs
selling off billion in cash canceling
projects they they could pay because it
looks like they got around 14 billion in
cash if they absolutely needed to spend
it um you know that Sony has that yeah
no no but yeah but obviously PlayStation
don't got that like they're gonna have
to look at at dad like can you pay my
f
yeah it would it would hurt them a
little bit yeah hey you know when not to
go back to what what you was saying
earlier gamly but you made a great point
about the
PS3 the Xbox listen if the PS3 I'm sorry
if the PS4 would have failed PlayStation
would probably be third party now
because even though they did eventually
outsell the 360 far as councils if you
look at software sold Xbox 360s out
absolutely destroyed them throughout
that generation if the PS4 would have
failed they probably would have been out
of here just like Xbox was almost out of
here but because Microsoft is Microsoft
but they still about to get rid of Xbox
man let's talk about it they were about
to get rid of Xbox Phil spcer had to
show show s Nela why Xbox is important
and the same thing with Nintendo the Wii
U was such a failure if the switch
wouldn't have took off Nintendo might
have been out of here bro there might
have been third party so you right about
that what you say earlier sorry to bring
it up now but I meant to bring it up
earlier yeah uh to to just add to that
sorry addict I'm so sorry you're fine um
to to add on to that like like I said
the Nostalgia for these companies really
like they've had decades to grow Their
audience and to form and they've been
through their own kind of battles with
other small groups right Sega at Sega
was not uh Microsoft you know Sega was
Sega you know they had
yeah exactly uh and you saw what Sega
did right when they couldn't when when
one of their consoles failed and then
another one wasn't as popular and then
they were out of here the same could
have happened to any of these companies
but Sony uh blowing up and having to DVD
player by the way which helped them a
lot um like a ton it helped them a ton
oh absolutely I say it all the time that
that them having that 150 whatever
million people going into the Next
Generation while they had Microsoft at
like what nothing right so you're
talking about a company that's just
getting into their game right uh you
just had a banger last gen console like
it should have been stomping yard for
them against Microsoft but they built
they showed Halo they changed the
landscape they went into multiplayer
they went into a direction that Sony
didn't understand which is exact L what
they're doing with live service games by
the way and and exactly what they're
doing with Game Pass and and all that
stuff they're pivoting right to win and
that's what exactly what's going to
happen but yeah if the roles were
reversed and Sony didn't have all that
Nostalgia oh man if the roles were rever
reversed and they were the ones putting
out Xbox One and they came off of a me
console and they were the new guys on
the Block Sony would be out cu they just
don't have the capital to to to lose
that much money
Microsoft though Microsoft does yeah and
that's why they're
here oh my God Donna Taco calling me out
Addie what's
new Donna t d the Nintendo the taku
calling me out man what Super
Chat tell me Nintendo could have three
Wii U and still be okay you forget they
had the 3DS which was still pretty
successful and they don't sell out a
think that nint you think they could had
three straight three they went for 100
million we to 13 million Wii U do you
think they would have been okay bro I'm
actually I would debate I would debate
after the second one they would just
they would gut the whole console thing
and
just yeah they actually had such okay
they have the most iconic most my God
they they destroy Sony and icon power
right completely and will'll always do
that but they had Mario Pokemon blah
blah blah they had two platforms they
were supporting they were down so bad
that they're like well we have a winning
like kind of formula both of our
consoles do good the 3DS and the Wii
let's say they do good they s sell
amazing so why why only make one right
why not capture everybody
right they lost they they looked at that
and they were like my God we we messed
up so bad here we sold so little that
we're going to combine that's our Niche
that's our pivot we're going to combine
the handheld and the Home console that
was the last thing we're going to lean
on Pokemon which is now being leaned on
way more than it used to be it's like
every year out every year right so they
were like we have these I you know
Nintendo was in trouble when they're
leaning on Pokemon right and they were
leaning on Mario Kart they never leaned
on Mario Kart as hard they did now and
on the Wii U era
so we know M we know Nintendo was like
oh my God help you know for real I feel
you let me get these and if they had
another one of that if they if they had
a 13 imagine if the switch did 13
million and and they did the same thing
now and it wasn't picking up imagine
where they'd be they Microsoft would be
Microsoft would be like all right come
here come here boy I'll help yeah and
they'd be like okay so we got $5 per Che
from JD gamer GTA 6 exclusive plus extra
content with for how do you have extra
like if you have GTA exclusive you don't
need extra content because it's on their
platform I get what you're saying though
JD gamer would force people to change
platforms and that is what Xbox needs I
agree JD gamer isn't wrong you know a
GTA 6 exclusive would be devastating to
PlayStation but the odds of that
happening I would say is so low it's
czy I'mma say I'm G say 1% we got5 we
got a $5 Super Chat from JD gamer PS is
being sued for not allowing digital
content from anywhere but the PS store
and overcharging for that digital
content uh $70 for three year old games
yeah man it's crazy hey make somebody
told me in my stream earlier that
returnal is still full price on the
PlayStation Store I don't know if that's
true or not that's crazy man that's a
2021 game wouldn't surprise me though
then we got two CH from JD gamer adct I
Love the remix of my clip you did
fire oh my God five out super chat
from F fantis arer fantis Archer if Sony
loses that case in the UK Sony has to
worry about the same thing in the US and
he's got a point there if they lose that
case in the UK I bet you it's GNA even
like spark a more of of lawsuits I don't
know though I don't know how stuff like
that works $ from the angry therapist
they don't have the money they bought
Bungie on the lay
away hey hey it definitely seems like
that my girl look PR good man one
guy I love every time I say that it
always makes your bless I gotta say it
it made me blush I was like oh my God
okay um
so uh so somebody laughed at me and said
oh yeah Mario Kart uh always sell good
I'm it's like guys that's not that's not
the point first off Mario Kart 7 18ish
million 20ish million Mario Kart right
now uh 58 million and they consistently
update the content and they consistently
bundle it and they consistently Push It
smash and Mario Kart have been pushed a
lot more here because they really had to
lean off that loss of the Wii okay they
really uh the Wii U they really had to
lean into Mario Kart and try to push
that and and and put it in front of
people's eyes again people was asking to
explain the lawsuit uh JD gamer did a
really good job so I read that Super
Chat yes go ahead sorry no no I was just
showing what people want they're pretty
much being sued because they're
dictating they're they're making a wall
garden and not only do they have a wall
Garden but they're saying you can't you
you can't do anything outside of that
wall Garden to affect the wall Gardens
so you that's why they took the uh you
know digital currency off Amazon like
you have to go through their wall Garden
there's no there's no Trojan horses you
could sneak up in that [__] you got to
use they stuff and and I guess people
are upset with that I don't know we got
a $5 super chart from the angry
therapist a million dooll company asks
you to pay a bill on a monthly payment
plan we're going to go ahead and you
know s out of here man first off you
appreciate the guest
man I got to follow you on Twitter bro
I'm terrible on Twitter just I just
communicate with you man I gotta
communicate with you I have to be a
guest on my
podcast he loves the messiness man and
you you about the messiness so so I'm
sure dirt there's Sparks in dirt
head well look look at my look at my my
room you know I have a a PlayStation 5
right here I have you know a handheld
Nintendo console I have a Xbox console I
love Xbox you you heard my background in
irel Lords I'm I'm a gamer uh but I am
spicy and I'm a gamer and I'm the person
the way I am because of the terrible
controller of the play PlayStation 5
just going to play it out there just a
terrible controller anyways I love you
guys so what what you got going on there
dirt man tell tell the realm what you
got going on uh nothing much man I did a
oneman podcast earlier today know
usually I I do it on you know Thursday
but obviously tomorrow there
Thanksgiving here in the states um so
yeah I did it early man I was having a
good time talking trash about the the
lawsuit about you know console sales and
other stuff so yeah that that was but
that's about it
man about it let me get the last uh so
let's just say I'm gonna say 37 minutes
for the time stamp I know if I don't get
that people going to be upset with me no
time man the time stamp time stamp Mafia
man yo uh you got anything going on
gazley like what's what you got going on
oh man no I'm just I'm gonna I'm I'm
gaming I'm kicking I'm listening to you
guys I'm listening
to you you should I guess right now you
know announce when you coming on dirt
show because I guess it's let's go dirt
when when we going dirt get me in there
I'll definitely
got $5 Super Chat for Nintendo Don
theotaku have to give Nintendo credit
the CEO took a pay cut in order man in
order to not lay off any employees I I I
feel like that's like a common thing
that happens like in Japan and other
countries it's only America that you
know I mean there's other countries
obviously but I do feel like it's worse
in the states like our corporate
structure they they will easily lay off
everyone they don't
care uh and you know me you guys can
catch me on the gaming addict channel uh
there it is in the in the chat
definitely go and sub to that been
making a lot of content I got I made a
content today about uh you know kns of
the Republic a lot of people got upset
over it because apparently I I can't
have an opinion but that's fine uh
because uh that's why I make my videos
because I want my opinion and it is what
it is at that
point oh go ahead I was gonna say so
definitely go check that out if you guys
want I'm pretty sure everyone coming
through we had like almost 4 like 30 40
people in here it was a it's fantastic
show the guest 500 yeah g guest being
extra extra spicy just like I thought he
would you know him and dirt definitely
bonded so definitely look look into that
yeah I just I just followed you on
Twitter brother yeah I'm terrible on
that you know what I'm always on um I'm
always a better platform is Instagram
you know I'm at uh Anthony Capello 5 two
L's 2 PS in Capello um that's where I do
most of my stuff I'm I'm more Sports
focused on the Instagram and um if you
want to send me a follow and look at
some cool kicks just go uh check me out
there all right yeah so uh definitely
check that I think we're gonna send you
guys over there to uh to fame we're
gonna send you guys over to fame U Got a
good show going on go guys tell them uh
you know adct show sent you and hope you
guys have a good time and uh we out
peace out CIA
guys